Boa noite a todos vocês sejam bem-vindos
a mais uma live dos apoiadores da parte
fechada do canal do Dr alã bem como de
pra nós vamos começar aqui com os
artigos interessantes temos hoje por
volta de 20 perguntas aí para responder
então acho que eu vou ser mais breve nos
artigos e partir pras perguntas porque
semana passada a gente não teve tempo de
responder as dúvidas ao vivo bem
primeira coisa que discutir com vocês
aqui um artigo
interessante que se refere ao vírus tá
eu nem vou falar o nome dele porque nem
sei se na área fechada tem problema mas
aquele vírus lá do ocorrido em 2019 tá
então um estudo que mostrou o uso de um
aminoácido
glicina se essa suplementação de glicina
que o aminoá que eu gosto muito
inclusive vai sair um vídeo ou se não
for semana que vem na outra semana sobre
glicina no canal na parte aberta Então
esse estudo procura saber se esse
aminoácido Poderia ajudar a reduzir a
mortalidade ou tempo de ventilação
mecânica nesses pacientes graves dessa
doença aí
problemática Boa noite Mar boa boa noite
Carlos então participado desse estudo 68
pacientes com média de idade 56 anos
sendo 58 homens e 10 mulheres Todos
estavam hospitalizados com aquele vírus
e necessit de ventilação mecânica então
a ideia era observar essa glicina esse
aminoácido que é muito interessante para
aumentar a glutationa para melhorar o
colágeno tem várias aí aplicações Então
se esse aminoácido poderia oferecer
algum benefício adicional tratamento
padrão então o estudo segundo consta foi
conduzido de maneira rigorosa os
participantes foram divididos em dois
grupos de maneira aleatória o grupo
controle que recebeu cuidado normal de
UTI e o grupo que recebeu além do
Cuidado habitual a suplementação enteral
ou seja recebeu a glicina através de
sonda nas enteral um tubo que vai do
nariz até a parte do intestino então a
dose administrada foi de 5 G né o 500 mg
por kilg de peso corporal por dia o
máximo de 40 G por dia tá uma dose bem
alta né 40 G Aí dependendo do
peso então a glicina foi entregue
diretamente ao intestino via sondan
gástrica análise interal e infelizmente
os resultados mostraram que a
suplementação do gcina não fez diferença
não reduziu a taxa de mortalidade nem o
tempo de ventilação mecânica no grupo da
glicina a taxa de mortalidade foi de 63%
enquanto no grupo controle foi de 52
Então não teve diferença estatística
entre os dois
grupos Então pelo menos nesse estudo a
glicina não trouxe benefícios que a
gente poderia experimentar agora o que
que eu teria feito diferente teria feito
glic com nac eu teria acrescentado a NS
cisteína ao
glicina eu acho que se eu fosse fazer um
próximo estudo desse eu faria os dois
juntos o próximo estudo é uma metanálise
que bem interessante para verificar Sea
suplementação com lactobacilos reutter é
um tipo de probiótico você acha na
manipulação e também acha em produtos
que você compra
pronto para melhorar os desfechos
clínicos né de pessoas com infecção pelo
HP lora aquela bactéria do estômago né
que todos vocês provavelmente já
conhecem eu já ouviram falar então a
intenção era entender se o uso do lact
lactobacilos reuter poderia fazer
diferença ajudar no tratamento na
radicação do HP Lore então metanálise
que ou seja um estudo que juntou vários
outros estudos numa análise só
investigou a eficácia da suplementação
com lactobacilos eut na melhora dos
desfechos clínicos em pacientes com
infecção prapor Então os principais
resultados foram taxa de radicação dessa
bactéria incidência de efeitos adversos
como náusea vômito dor abdominal e
diarreia e sintomas gastrointestinais
que foram Auto avaliadas Ou seja a
própria pessoa relatou através de uma
escala de sintomas gastrointestinais
então preencheu um questionário esse
para dizer se tinha melhorado esses
sintomas náusea vômito dor abdominal
diarreia então eles foram estudados
cerca de 1087 participantes todos eles
com infecção comprovada por h piló e foi
vários países do mundo foram Itália Irã
China Tailândia Egito e Malásia então um
grupo bem diversificado em termos aí de
etnia né a metanálise incluiu oito
estudos clínicos Sand amizad todos os
outros estudos então eram de alta
qualidade eram randomizados os
participantes suplementaram diariamente
com diferentes cepas né diferentes tipos
de L rutere de lactobacilos reuter aí
não vou falar aqui que é tudo sopa de
letrinha Tá dsm 17938 então não vou
falar não basta saber que são vários
tipos de lactobacilos
reutter o grupo de controle recebeu um
Placebo ou seja pilo de farinha e a
duração da intervenção foi de 14 a 30
dias e o segmento foi de 4 Semanas a 96
dias e os resultados mostraram que
comparado a pilor de farinha Placebo a
taxa de radicação da H pilor foi maior
com a suplementação com reuter foi 80%
contra 72 por. Além disso houve melhoras
nos sintomas gastrointestinais uma
redução de 28% no risco de eventos
adversos em comparação com o
Placebo Então essa meta análise sugere
que a suplementação com lactobacilos
reuter pode melhorar a taxa de radicação
da bactéria helicobacter pilor ou H
pilor reduzir sintomas gastrointestinais
e diminuir o risco de eventos
exos são achados promissores mas devemos
considerar que apenas dois estudos
avaliaram os eventos
adversos Então temos que analisar essa
descoberta com
cautela beleza pessoal bem vamos para
paraas perguntas
aqui eu vou deixar o terceiro artivo
paraa semana que
vem tá a primeira pergunta
é de Marta
Perez Qual a minha opinião sobre o uso
do Sam no tratamento da fibromialgia
depressão e doenças do fígado Eu gosto
bastante do Sam viu ele pode ajudar sim
nessas
doenças em alguns estudos o Sam foi
utilizado em conjunto com
antidepressivos e Foi útil para pessoas
com depressão resistente ao tratamento
convencional teve um estudos duplo cego
randomizado com 73 participantes que não
responderam à terapia com
antidepressivos inibidores da recaptação
seletiva de serotonina e mostrou que o
Sam numa dose alta né porque é um
suplemento caro de 800 MG duas vezes ao
dia em combinação com esses
antidepressivos mostrou uma melhor taxa
de resposta em relação a
Placebo então em relação a depressão É
bem interessante em relação a doenças
hepáticas né Eh nós sabemos que o Sam é
produzido naturalmente pelo fígado e tem
um papel crucial na
metilação também mais de 100 reações
metabólicas tá envolvido no detox
hepático é importante
antioxidante o Sam foi demonstrado em
estudos que pode ser eficaz no
tratamento de hepatite alcoólica e
cirrose hepática em pacientes com
cirrose hepática alcoólica uso de Sam
ajudou a aumentar a sobrevida então ele
tem uma ação
hepatoprotetora pode reduzir o risco de
desenvolver o câncer de estômago
desculpa o câncer de fígado e outras
doenças desse órgão inclusive
cirrose para fibromialgia tem menos
estudos mas sabemos que o Sam pode
ajudar a aliviar sintomas mas associado
à dor e fadiga dessa doença então é
interessante sim ele pode ser usado como
um agente adjuvante um ag gente que vai
ajudar a
complementar vamos paraa próxima
pergunta do Antônio Renato diabetes tem
cura até que ponto tem cura Só se foi
feita a diata no início ou se dê o
descanso ao pâncreas e depois consumir
carboidrato ainda que pouco mais acima
da acetose o Diabetes volta tá primeiro
ponto o diabetes tipo um em geral não
tem cura é uma doença autoimune e
geralmente quando é diagnosticado o
pâncreas já foi bem debilitado as
células Beta pancreáticas já foram
destruídas então não tem muito o que
fazer se você tiver uma sorte muito
grande descobrir o diabético um antes de
ter a a falência da células Bet
pancreáticas dá para tentar tratar com
naltrexona mas eu acho bem difícil
conseguir descobrir a
tempo diabetes tipo do é reversível não
podemos falar de cura definitiva mas ele
é reversível com a dieta cetogênica ele
vai entrar em
remissão óbvio que além da dieta
cetogênica é importante também atividade
física e melhora dos atos de vida com
melhora do sono
e do
estresse a questão da reintrodução dos
carboidratos é muito variável de pessoa
paraa pessoa tem gente que vai conseguir
ter a manutenção da reversão não cura né
como eu tô frisando aqui vai conseguir
ter manutenção da reversão se
reintroduzir um pouquinho de carboidrato
e tem pessoas que não que tem
intolerância muito grande a carboidrato
e não vão poder sair da cetogênica então
é variável de pessoa para pessoa
portanto é muito necessário manter uma
vigilância
contínua isso é o mais difícil porque as
pessoas geralmente não tem essa
disciplina
né Lembrando que o que funciona para uma
pessoa não pode funcionar às vezes
necessariamente para outra
pessoa certo vamos para próxima
[Música]
pergunta do antnio Renato se a pessoa
ficar só de cueca sentarse numa cadeira
com o rosto coberto já é suficiente para
repor vitamina D sim não precisa ficar
necessariamente eu tô entendendo aqui
que você tá falando de ficar deitado né
o ideal é você não ficar deitado porque
aí você vai ter a exposição solar tanto
nas costas Quanto na parte da frente mas
sim Teoricamente você poderia conseguir
somente com a parte da frente
anterior exposição solar suficiente para
ter vitamina n d Ok e você tem que ficar
dependendo da cor de pele for muito
clara a cor de pele de 10 a 15 minutos
se for uma cor mais Morena 20 a 30
minutos se for uma pessoa bem escura se
uma pele bem eh Negra aí quase uma hora
de sol né que seria o
recomendado tá então se você fosse expor
ao sol Tenta fazer isso sentado né e não
deitar eu tô entendendo que você tá
cobrindo o rosto você tá deitando de
barriga para cima se você puder fazer
isso
de sentado é melhor
tá vamos pra próxima
pergunta pessoas TM problemas nervosos
que tem vitamina D baixa de 30 por
exemplo aumentar para 80 e acrescentar
ômega-3 pode ter uma melhora no sono
depende sim é possível que melhore tem
estudos mostrando a correlação entre
vitamina D e a saúde mental então
pessoas tem vitamina D mais alta tem
melhor saúde mental então a vitamina D
pode ajudar a tratar depressão e
ansiedade Eu fiz um vídeo sobre isso
muitos anos atrás deve ter mais de 6
anos tem um estudo brasileiro que
mostrou que idosos com deficiência de
vitamina D podde ter de duas a três
vezes mais Chan de apresentar sintomas
depressivos já a questão do ômega-3
também tem estudos mostrando o efeito do
ômega-3 positivos na redução de
depressão e ansiedade
o CTA do ômega-3 ser um dos componentes
da parede do
neurônio então ele ajuda a regular o
humor ajuda a regular o estresse mas não
tem como garantir que só com vitamina D
e ômega3 a pessoa vai resolver de todos
os problemas
dos neurônios tá isso é individual pode
ter outras causas gerando
problema Antônio Renato para cada 1000
10.000 unidades de vitamina D e 100 de
K2 é na maioria dos lugares é assim tá
isso não é escrito em pedra não é uma
coisa definitiva mas se recomenda sim
que a cada 10.000 unidades de vitamina
D3 você use 100 mg de K2 mas tem outras
proporções aí tem gente usando por
exemplo a proporção de 10.000 de D3 para
200 mg de K2 então isso não é uma coisa
totalmente definitiva ainda tá Por que
que a K2 é importante é importante para
evitar que a o cálcio que aumenta a
absorção com a d não vai parar no lugar
errado né é para garantir que esse
cálcio vai pro osso e não para pared da
artéria ou para outros
órgãos ideal você manter a sua vitamina
D entre 4070 tem autor que fala entre 60
e 80 isso ainda não é
definitivo e a K2 bem segura mas eu acho
que o limite de segurança é por volta de
500 mic por dia eu não tomaria mais do
que isso de K2
não
Carlos toda vez que faço Hi aumenta
imediatamente o descarte de água do
corpo por um tempo urinando muito sim é
fato
isso o corpo trabalha mais deshidratado
durante a dieta não a explicação para
isso é que quando você faz dieta
cetogênica Você tem uma depleção de
glicogênio tá então você vai o organismo
vai queimando o glicogênio do fígado e
dos
músculos e o glicogênio tá ligado à água
dentro do organismo Quando você vai
queimando o glicogênio a água vai sair
do
junto cada grama de glicogênio armazena
de 3 A 4 g de água então quando quebra
ou depleta o glicogênio essa água sai
junto ela ela excretada pelos INSS outra
causa para isso é que os copos cetônicos
produzidos pelo na dieta tem um efeito
natriurético Ou seja faz eliminar sódio
e o sódio carrega a água também pelos
vins isso Geralmente só acontece nos
estágios iniciais da dieta
a terceira explicação é que a insulina
vai reduzindo no seu organismo e ela tem
um efeito anatur Ou seja quando a
insulina tá alta ela tende a reter sódio
e água quando a insulina cai com a dieta
cetogênica também vai diminuir a
retenção de sódio e
água a quarta razão para isso é que as
acetonas são excretadas na urina levando
consigo água adicional tá Então qual que
é o ponto aqui quando você tá começando
a fazer a cetogênica você corre o risco
de ter a tal
da gripe queto né quet oflu para evitar
isso tem que aumentar a ingestão de água
aumentar a ingestão de sal
integral e de outros eletrólitos como
Magnésio e potássio para isso mais
interessante é você comer bastante
abacate e monitorar sinais de
desidratação como seria sede excessiva
urina escura fadiga e tontura então toma
muito cuidado para não ficar
desidratado
excessivamente Eliseu qualquer fungo na
vagina aumenta o risco de infertilidade
não o os fungos na vagina podem indireto
de risco de infertilidade mas a relação
não é direta
[Música]
Tá qual é a ação indireta da candidíase
que é o fungo mais comum na
infertilidade porque a cândida aenta
né altera Na verdade o PH vaginal
tornando esse ambiente menos receptivo
aos espermatozóides então ele fica mais
ácido o ambiente vaginal ele pode
espessar o muco cervical né a cândida
Isso dificulta passagem espermatozoide e
também pode causar Don na relação sexual
isso reduz a frequência de coitos né E
também reduz o o a chance de
engravidar porém não é comum que a
cândida cause danos permanentes no
sistema reprodutivo feminino a ponto de
causar fertilidade
infertilidade Eliseu esse suplemento que
possui dois vírus que matam fungo
Cândida funciona é confiável Ele cura
candis mais rápido que a Zon terapia
depois de curar candidas é possível
matar esses dois vírus facilmente tá eu
fui ver o que que era que você tava
falando eu dei uma olhada no no vídeo Tá
Na verdade é um suplemento que tem
tributirina né que é uma forma aí de
ácido butírico que são três moléculas de
ácido butírico juntas isso tem efeito an
fúndico mesmo tá ajuda a matar a cândida
e ele tá também associando aí
um dois bacteriófagos que que é
bacteriófagos são vírus que infectam e
matam bactérias então achei estranho
porque bacteriófago Teoricamente é um
vírus que ataca bactéria não que ataca
fungo e eu não conhecia esse uso eu não
posso afirmar que vai funcionar porque
eu não vi e não achei estudo sobre isso
tá também não procurei muito não tive
tempo de ficar olhando ISO com muito
detalhe Eu fiz um vídeo sobre
bacteriófagos mas eu tava falando no uso
para bactérias não para fungos Ok então
eu acho meio estranho tá utilizando
bacteriófago para matar fungo porque é
um é um vírus especializado em matar
bactéria Ok se eu tiver mais informações
no futuro sobre isso eu vou passar para
vocês Tá mas a princípio eu não endosso
porque eu não nunca visto em lugar
nenhum usar bacteriófago para matar
Cândida
tá antigamente há uns 5 anos mais ou
menos você fazia vídeos com 1 hora de
duração sim eu fazia
usando PowerPoint o conteúdo era rico
por que você não volta a fazer eu não
volto a fazer li porque as pessoas não
assistem só por isso tá eh as pessoas
hoje em dia não querem assistir vídeo
longo Então eu preciso fazer o canal do
YouTube ser um canal que pelo menos
pague parte das despesas que eu tenho
com a gerência de marketing que eu
contrato para ajudar a trazer pacientes
pro consultório tá Inclusive eu tô
seriamente pensando em demitir a
gerência de marketing porque é bem caro
e o canal do YouTube não dá retorno para
pagar esse investimento aí mas aí é um
desentendimento que eu tô tendo com a
minha esposa que acha que eu devo
continuar pagando isso
daí algumas lives atrás você comentou
sobre isso de raspão parece que ingeri o
suplemento enzimas digestivas de
estômago vazio contanto que sejam duas
horas depois de comer possuem um efeito
diferente sim o efeito diferente que eu
tava falando é que essas enzimas
especialmente a bromelina e a papaína
mas tem outras também elas são
absorvidas pelo intestino em vez de ser
utilizadas na digestão se você ingere
elas de jejum e o efeito sistêmico é
antiinflamatório essas enzimas como a
bromelina e papaína
vão circular pelo sangue e vão quebrar
imunocomplexos que são o quê são
anticorpos que podem
est vagando no seu sangue eh estejam
combatendo algum tipo de agente
invasor então tem estudos mostrando que
essas enzimas temm ação antioxidante
antiinflamatória antioxidante ajudam o
sistema imune
tá poderiam também ajudar a melhorar a
circulação
sanguínea Então são estudos iniciais
ainda Precisa mais pesquisa sobre esse
assunto mas é é interessante porque eu
já usei bastante enzimas desse tipo para
tratamento de prostatite por exemplo ou
de pessoas que têm asma brônquica né
bronquite de repetição com mesmo
sinusite você disse no YouTube que a
dose suplemento garra do diabo depende
da idade não eu acho que você tava
confundindo porque na verdade Depende de
se é criança né Se for criança a dose é
diferente mas para adulto não varia
tanto e a dose deárea Se você usar um
produto rico em arpag
é de 30 a 100 mg por
dia tem um estudo que usou 2 g do
extrato por dia não era o concentrado
durante se semanas e melhorou 85% dor
lumbar e de outras articulações se você
for tomar em forma de chá a recomendação
É Beber de duas a trê xícaras por
dia tá se for
criança grir falando se for criança com
menos de k você pode usar 1/4 da dose
que eu acabei de falar se for criança
entre 20 e 50 kg você usa metade da dose
Mas isso é uma coisa bem grosseira tá
não tô endossando isso tô dando uma
orientação geral para
vocês limão corta o efeito da
ozonioterapia nunca vi nada a respeito
acho que não
Eliseu Se você souber de onde saiu essa
informação seria interessante Por que
que é melhor fazer oson terapia em jejum
Não faço ideia Nunca tive essa Aliás
você já perguntou isso eliz eu já
respondi em outra Live não tem indicação
de jejum para fazer zonoterapia não
conheço qual seria só se for zonoterapia
retal mesmo assim não faria muito
sentido de novo a história de tomar sol
de cueca
[Música]
né Eu já respondi a respeito disso aqui
deixa eu ver se tem alguma coisa aqui
que eu não
falei não essa história de tomar banho
depois do banho de sol tem um vídeo
antigo do L Ribeiro falando que tem que
esperar uma hora para tomar banho eu não
acho que isso seja relevante não tá se
você fizer questão de seguir a
orientação do Dr Lair espera uma hora
para tomar banho mas eu acho que isso é
bobagem Tá qual é o máximo vitamina D
que o sol no Media sem interrupção pode
dar uma pessoa no máximo 20.000 mas o
mais comum é 10.000 por dia tá
a vitamina D manipulada pode não ser
absorvida corretamente caso os
receptores estejam comprometidos sim se
você tiver a mutação do vdr que é o
receptor de vitamina D Você vai precisar
de mais vitamina D para ter o mesmo
efeito Ok tanto para vitamina D tomada
como suplemento tanto para absorção pelo
sol ok
em fevereiro uma pessoa começou a ter
dificuldade evacuar doia muito para sair
depois de umas duas ou três vezes saiu
sangue vermelho em cima das feses pois
ela tinha uma alimentação pobre em
fibras mal almoçava direito então
aproximadamente em abril ela fez uma
colonoscopia O médico disse que não deu
nada a pessoa questionou o médico do
sangue O médico disse que tinha uma
fissura fissura pode dar sangue tá Não
precisa ter câncer no intestino para ter
sangue e a pessoa questionou pois não
sentia dor e viu na internet que fissura
D dor sim na maioria das vezes não todas
fissura da dor ele disz que na prática
atende muitas pessoas e que não
necessariamente dá dor aí a pessoa se
lembrou que se alimentava mal e que a
dor qu deve ter ferido anos sim pode ter
saído fezes endurecidas e machucado e
sai do
sangue e mesmo sem sentir dor viu sangue
depois de ir ao médico a pessoa começou
a se alimentar com feijão e arroz e a
constipação sumiu e a dificuldade de
evacuar também passou ela passou a
evacuar uma vez por dia não teve mais
dor recentemente essa pessoa sentiu dor
uma vez e se viu o sangue de novo
pergunta você se qualquer pessoa se
alimenta mal por um período longo ela
está pobre em fibras e água e sono
péssimo também com a dificuldade de
evacuar Pode sangrar sim Pode sangrar
sem necessariamente ser água grave Mesmo
que não seja des grave sim e após o
primeiro sagramento pode ter leves não
sei o que que é
leves e se
voltar a se alimentar bem o
desaparecimento das dificuldades de
evacuar e constipação volta a normal sim
pode voltar ou sempre é preocupante não
tem sangue tem que fazer colonoscopia
mas nem sempre a colonoscopia vai dar
algo que seja grave Tá
certo sangramento pode ser das fezes
endurecidas pode ser de fissura pode ser
de hemorroida que são coisas mais
benignas ok
então sempre manter uma dieta rica em
fibras rica em
água é muito importante ter hábitos
intestinais bons também não ficar
segurando as feses isso tudo vai
ajudar ausência de fibras consumo arrado
que que é arrado
Não sei vou vou entender como consumo
pouco de água alimentação de massas e
biscoitos tudo errado pode casador
evacuar sim pode já expliquei isso agora
a pouco consequentemente sangue vermelho
Sim sempre é ág preocupante não o médico
falou que eu limpei 90% do meu intestino
e segundo ele o aceitável para fazer
colonoscopia pois ele com mangueira
limpa dentro e vê se tem algo errado sim
se for um câncer a colonoscopia vai
identificar agora outras coisas mais
sutis não tipo intestino irritável
geralmente a colonoscopia não dá nada e
a doença existe né Nem toda doença é
anatômica no caso do câncer sim vai ter
uma lesão anatômica as fezes sempre
boiando é um sinal de que algo está
errado não
necessariamente pode ser
por excesso de fibra na alimentação por
exemplo
pode boiar mas pode ser um problema mais
sério como excesso de gordura nas fezes
ou pode ser excesso de fermentação
bacteriana se ela bói uma vez e outras
não é normal sim normal como e uma fezes
de uma pessoa como é uma como é são as
fezes de uma pessoa com intestino
saudável geralmente é um formato de
banana e são fezes bem formadas e deixa
pouco resíduo no papel Quando você vai
se limpar certo as fees com sangue
vermelho saíram em pedaços e o pedaço
maior que do eu saiu com sangue vermelho
tá Já já já discutimos muito sobre isso
já né Deu para
entender por favor Cite os exames para
detectar cânceres precocemente
tem vários aí os mais que são divulgados
pela mídia mamografia que eu sou contra
fazer todos os anos por causa da
radiação mamografia vocês sabem é
utilizada para detectar câncer de mama a
partir dos 40 anos de idade agora eles
estão propondo diminuir a idade das
mulheres porque cada vez mais tá
aparecendo mulher antes dos 30 com
câncer o Papa Nicolau é o principal
exame para colo de útero tumor de colo
de útero né o Tor de chamado câncer
cervical tem que ser feito uma vez por
ano as mulheres a partir dos 21 anos a
colonoscopia que acabamos de falar antes
era a partir dos 50 agora também tá
ficando comum câncer de intestino grosso
antes dos 50 então o recomendado é fazer
de rotina a partir dos
40 PS que a partir dos 50 anos ou dos 45
dependendo do caso que é um exame de
sangue para detectar tentar detectar
precocemente o câncer de próstata apesar
do PSA ser muito
falho pessoas que têm S Tomas no pulmão
por exemplo e fumam muito faz sentido
fazer uma tomografia computadorizada com
baixa dose de
radiação também o câncer de pele que é
muito comum aí é expressão visual né por
um profissional com experiência da pele
para detectar possíveis câncer de pele
como melanoma tem um ex dermatoscopia tá
para dentificar melanoma ou outros tipo
de câncer de pele endoscopia digestiva
alta para tentar ficar câncer de
estômago
esôfago e existem uns anos laboratoriais
que são os marcadores que eu não
recomendo utilizar de rotina porque eles
são marcadores que foram desenvolvidos
para controle de cura e não para
diagnóstico porque muitas vezes esses
marcadores estão
aumentados e a pessoa fica nervosa à toa
porque não é câncer tá é o caso do
ca15 do ca40 do
CIA e de outros marcadores de sangue tá
então agora estão sendo desenvolvidos
ainda não estão disponíveis testes novos
para detecção de múltiplos cânceres que
seriam exame de sangue existe a biópsia
líquida mas ela não pegou porque ela era
muito cara mas existe agora outros
exames parecidos com a biópsia líquida
que são sendo desenvolvidos muitos deles
eh utilizam a tecnologia aí de para
identificar
os lipossomas
né mas ainda não estão disponíveis na
prática
Clínica Por que algumas pessoas têm que
tirar apêndice porque essa glândula
apêndice pode inflamar causando
apendicite E se ele não for removido a
pessoa pode morrer de infecção
abdominal existe uma situação que é o
plastrão apendicular Né o abcesso que é
mais raro e que às vezes pode evitar a
cirurgia tá quando eu tava na residência
cirurgia geral há 25 anos atrás a gente
fez alguns estudos lá na
unib sobre isso eu não sei se isso foi
paraa frente porque a rotina naquela
época era fazer apendicectomia ou
retirar o apêndice até para plastrão
pendicular eu não sei se aqueles estudos
que a gente fez que conseguiu tratar só
com
antibiótico e não teve peritonite né não
rompeu o a pên dentro da cavidade
abdominal e não causou infecção
Grave Se isso foi pra frente eu teria
que ver mas a princípio sim se retira o
ap senão a pessoa pode morrer de sepse
né de infecção
[Música]
generalizada o impacto paraa saúde o
apes ele faz parte do sistema imune tá
ele é um tecido linfoide
geralmente a sua remoção não causa
grandes
problemas mas reduz um pouco a defesa do
organismo da
pessoa então complicações da cirurgia
pode ficar uma cicatriz feia pode
infeccionar a cicatriz pode ter uma
cicatri adequada pode ter infecções
pós-operatórias no próprio intestino
aderências intestinais mas isso são
complicações difíceis aí de acontecer se
a técnica cirúrgica for
[Música]
adequada Thiago o senhor mencionou
semana passada quando perguntei sobre
reverter doença autoimune sobre a diat
autoimune paleolítica na sua opinião
essa seria a melhor dieta para esse fim
ou teria outra melhor e qual a sua
opinião sobre the walls protocol a dieta
do D Terry walls a dieta D Terry walls é
muito parecida com autoimune tá muito
parecida com autoimune paleolítica as
diferenças são muito sutis
tá vamos falar um pouco sobre isso a
dieta autoimune paleolítica é uma
variação mais restritiva da paleolítica
ela é focada em reduzir inflamação
sintomas de doenças autoimunes
é uma dieta muito restritiva tira grãos
tira leguminosas que é os feijões né as
favas e coisas semelhantes tira Laí tira
ovo tira alimento processado é difícil
de manter a longo prazo né como qualquer
dieta
restritiva e ela também não é permanente
a maioria dos pacientes reintroduz os
alimentos após alguns meses n é uma
reintrodução gradual dos alimentos o
protocolo da dieta walls
que foi desenvolvida pela Dora ter walls
para tratar a própria esclerose múltipla
dela é basicamente uma variação da
paleolítica só que ela tem uma ênfase um
pouco diferente no consumo de vegetais
el tem uma ênfase em Folhas
Verdes e mas é muito parecido
tá muito
parecido então o protocolo walls parece
que é um pouquinho mais estruturado tem
três níveis de restrição tem a walls
diet que é menos restritiva a walls
Paleo e a walls Paleo Plus que é mais
restritiva ainda então ela fez tipo
ajustes na dieta paleolítica tá depois
você pode estudar com
mais detalhe a dieta da qualquer uma
dessas duas dietas vão te ajudar tá você
pode fazer a que você achar que é mais
eficaz ou que você se identificar
mais Antônio Renato se eu que tenho 30
de vitamina D eu tô imaginando que é no
sangue tomar 30 comprimidos manipulados
de D de D3 10.000 Então vai dar 300.000
unidades e 100 microg de K2 tomar sol em
90% do corpo parte da frente do Sol no
meio-dia por 60 dias ininterruptos eu
posso em 2is meses normalizar os níveis
de vitamina
D para o menos 60
Depende mas tô achando você deve tá
falando 30 no sentido de ser um por dia
né n é 30 de uma vez
né creio que tem tant tem muita chance
de chegar nesse nível aí mas é
impossível prever que isso vai acontecer
tá eu não tenho um sono regenerador há
muitos anos tenho tido esquecimento de
coisas bem recentes sempre esquecendo a
chave
e outros objetos minha mãe também tem
sintomas eu fico meio lesado
desorientado sou viciado em doces açúcar
já ti diagnóstico de depressão desimi
transtor de ansiedade abandonei os
remédios e graças a Deus melhorei mas
isso pode ser relacionado eu posso estar
com sintomas de
demência é mais provável não sei a sua
idade não sei nada de você tá mas é mais
provável que você tá é com déficit de
sono e isso que tá gerando esquecimento
tá Então trate esse déf de sono trate
essa compulsão por
doces se você tirar o doce da sua vida
já vai desinflamar muito seu cérebro e
vai ajudar tratamento de
depressão falamos aqui do sam que ajuda
na depressão nessa Live você pode usar
também metiolate que ajuda tem vários
fitoterápicos que ajudam na depressão
CAV cava picon né que é a Eva de São
João tem ômega3 tem um monte de coisa
que pode ajudar na depressão tá
mas procure o médico para tratar dessa
sua situação de Déficit de sono e
compulsão por
doces se li marena 500 mg é seguro sim é
seguro pode ser consumido por todos
Praticamente sim só criança pequena que
eu não recomendaria essa dose tem que
ser acompanhado por algo mais sim Sempre
acompanhamento com médico ou
nutricionista
tá efeitos colaterais Depende se você
tiver com muita toxina no organismo pode
estar liberando as toxinas e isso gerar
sintomas como náusea vômito fraqueza
mal-estar tá são os mais
comuns quanto de sal integral máximo é
recomendado pelo senhor depende como é
que eu vou responder isso sem saber peso
sem saber idade sem saber nada
né grosseiramente Falando duas
colheres de café de sal integral por dia
tá
Mas isso é
variável
eass se eu conheço a medicação prefis
pregabalina Conheço caso positivo
poderia dizer se conhece riscos e
efeitos colaterais pelo uso durante 3
meses a pregabalina é muito interessante
para dor neuropática obviamente ela tem
sim efeitos
colaterais é uma droga poderosa Então
como qualquer outra droga poderosa vai
ter esses efeitos colaterais Eu
geralmente começo uma dose mais baixa de
25 MG por dia para evitar esses efeitos
os mais comuns são tontura sonolência
dor de cabeça visão turva boca seca
grande peso inchaço nas mãos e pés tá
constipação e
[Música]
náuseas o que causa mutação vdr
mutação como qualquer outra coisa ou
você rudou dos seus pais aí na
mutação que veio de né uma mutação que
veio
[Música]
dosa uma doença hereditária né mas a
mutação aconteceu nos seus pais não em
você ou você sofreu mutação
eh por algum momento da sua vida tá eu
não conheço nada específico que possa
evitar a mutação do
PDR eu vou tentar dar uma olhada nesse
assunto se existe alguma
coisa que não
[Música]
tá existe uma informação que casamentos
com sanguíneos entre parentes próximos
pode aumentar o risco de transmissão de
mutações genéticas áreas incluindo o
vdr mas realmente eu não tô achando nada
para prevenção só para tratamento que
seria Alas vitamina
D para compensar a
[Música]
mutação Então na verdade não existe é
prevenção
conhecida quando urin sinta um leve
desconforto na bexiga ou próstata Não
entendi essa pergunta
não não entendi essa pergunta tá mal
formulada você quer saber as causas de
desconforto na bexiga e próstata pode
ser infecção pode ser
trauma tanto infecção na bexiga quanto
infecção na próstata até infecção no
testículo pode gerar esses sintomas Tá
mas eu não sei se eu entendi a sua
pergunta Existe maneira de prevenir
problemas de apendice tendo uma dieta
rica em fibras é o jeito mais eficiente
de evitar apendicite tá ap tá muito
ligado à falta de fibra na
alimentação óleo de coco ainda indicado
por você por favor uma marca de manteiga
Gu manteiga Gu de cabeça não lembro de
uma marca não tá teria que pesquisar
isso eu recomendava até conversar com o
pessoal lá da associação de produtores
de coco do Nordeste Lógico eles T aí um
problema de conflito de interesse Mas
eles alegam que essas marcas de líder de
mercado o pessoal importa coco
desidratado do asiático na verdade eles
importam a água deshidratada e refazem
essa água no Brasil né fazem a
reconstituição então eles indic dizem
que além de ser uma água de coco de
qualidade ruim tô falando de água tá não
de óleo eles dizem que tem a questão lá
do dos Macacos para pegar o coco tá mas
assim o óleo de coco é diferente né Eu
não acho que ten esse problema tão
grande não eu acho que você pode usar
assim o o óleo de coco
cpra entre ômega-3 na Nutri Blu e deve
tá foco mais indicado entre esses dois
eu acho que o vitafor é um pouco melhor
tá quem tem mutação vdr não absorve
vitamina D não a a mutação vdr não tem
nada a ver com a absorção de vitamina D
tem a ver com a ação da vitamina D no
organismo tá como identificar com o
exame genético eu ten que fazer o exame
genético para ver se tem a mutação vdr
Tá bom vamos pesquisar isso
aí bem vamos
para paraas dúvidas aí do
pessoal que está acompanhando a Live ao
vivo
Eliseu entrei no banheiro público e ouvi
alguns homens urinando em intervalos Por
que que alguns homens urina em
intervalos porque provavelmente tem
alguma obstrução ou essa obstrução é
funcional é um cara que tem a bexiga eh
tímida né o shai bladder Né que é uma
pessoa que tem vergonha de urinar em
público ou pode ser um homem mais velho
prostático tá isso seria por causa de
masturbação Creio que não Eliseu tá
Pergunta lá pro cara no banheiro se ele
tá se mastubando Creio que não né não
seja essa a
questão Quais são os benefícios que a
pessoa pede ao ingerir limão ou caldo de
óo durante o
jejum Por que que pederia benefício
ingerindo limão em jejum ou caldo de
ossos não sei por que perderia benefício
elu a manter 130 MG deve ser 130 microg
né não sei de D3 no sangue não deve ser
Ah sim n por ml tá falando exame de
sangue O que que a pessoa precisa fazer
para prevenir diminuição da densidade
ossa primeiro eu não
faria não ficaria com esse nível de
vitamina D no sangue A não ser que fosse
uma doença
autoimune segundo uso de própolis e
magnésio ajuda a evitar esse problema aí
da diminuição da densidade
óssea para curar h de disco com a máxima
eficiência possível tem que fazer
ozonioterapia não não tem que fazer é
opcional tá ele ajuda mas não é
obrigatório fisioterapia PRP lógico
quanto mais coisa você fizer melhor tá
Boa noite Miria Boa noite
Cristina quanto ao uso do Sam existe
risco de aumento da miste não pelo
contrário ela vai baixar o Sam é s
adenosil metionina tá já é uma metionina
que foi processada pelo organismo então
geralmente o baixa atina não faz
aumentar tá
H2 tem que ser a trans
eh O ideal seria assim tá a trans tá
marca para indicar Life
extension Boa noite TAM miquinha selênio
armazena no corpo sim tem armazenamento
selênio apesar de ser limitado o que que
eu acho da dieta carnívora difícil de
seguir mais difícil do que a
paleolítica porque você tem que comer
carne e
vísceras precisa tomar betaína nessa
dieta deve tá falando cor hidrato e
betaína né não é betaína anidra que é
outra coisa sim é recomendado porque Vai
facilitar a digestão dessas proteínas tá
eu acho uma dieta muito interessante
para quem Dena autoimune uma alternativa
para doença perdão pra dieta autoimune
paleolítica e a da D ter wet comentou
aqui mais cedo na Live mas é muito
difícil de seguir na prática porque tem
que comer vísceras maior das pessoas não
tá disposta a comer isso é difícil
conseguir V ela também em Variedade
problemas com estamina pode virar asma
com tempo não e asma tem envolvimento da
estamina mas é uma situação diferente
por ser uma doença alérgica né do que
seria uma intolerância histamínica por
outra causa tá Então apesar das duas
situações terem envolvimento da estamina
a intolerância estam e a asma um não
leva a outro tá não são doas
diferentes eh acredito que a
intolerância amí não tem nada a ver com
asma não vai virar asma tá pode ter
sintomas tá que lembro muito a asma pela
inoran cínica mas aí não é que vai virar
asma não sei se você
entendeu o senhor tem recebido na sua
prática Clínica homens jovens com
problemas testiculares não com
frequência passado quando eu era mais
urologista
ortodoxo dores ou outros problemas p Ah
o vírus tá
oposto Não no momento eu não tô
recebendo isso mas não quer dizer que
não esteja acontecendo
tá
azon terapia em jejum que perguntei em
outra Live foi na Live passada porém não
foi
respondida não mas eu acho que eu
respondi isso Elisa Mas tudo bem
respondi hoje né ouvi que mocotó nos
frigoríficos são limpos com soda sim e é
muito comum o uso de soda em vários
lugares inclusive para mocotó
tá por exemplo é muito usado cal para
fazer açúcar
né então isso é É verdade
sim 30 um por dia tá então você já
esclareceu que era
[Música]
30.000 aliás que era 20 era 10.000
unidades 30 comprimidos um por
dia STF provou 40 g de maconha Quais as
consequências para saú é consumir 40 g
de maconha por dia e a longo prazo são
consequências bem importantes
[Música]
Tá mas por você tá preocupado exatamente
com essa quantidade de 40
G você vai carregar 40 g de maconha por
dia é isso
Eliseu 40 G é uma quantidade bem
considerável tá
É lógico que isso vai ser variável de
pessoa para pessoa
né mas é bastante quantidade né para
fumar num dia
só Provavelmente você vai ter
comprometimento cognitivo com perda de
memória raciocínio e concentração vai
ter mais chance de ter problemas
psiquiátricos se você tiver uma
tendência a frenia issso vai
aflorar vai danificar os pulmões vai
danificar o cérebro vai aumentar o risco
de
câncer aumentar o risco de bronquite de
tosse
crônica aumenta o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares também como AVC
arritmia
infarto tá bom
quando a pessoa para de usar suplemento
melatonina ela consegue produzir
naturalmente sim
consegue você acha uma boa ideia comprar
leite materno para beber não não
acho não acho uma boa ideia não vejo um
bom motivo para fazer
isso Ribeiro falou que exame de sangue
não dá para medir vitamina D não depende
você tem um 25 hidróxi vitamina D que é
o calcidiol e tem o calcitriol que é
1,25
hidróxi vitamina D então o exame
habitual é 25 hidróxi não é a forma
final da vitamina D e 1,25 apesar de ser
o hormônio final calcitriol é difícil de
medir porque a técnica Laboratorial é
muito complexa tem que congelar a
amostra antes de analisar então na
prática você faz eh o exame do calcidiol
Por que que é ruim acordar durante sono
rein
Não conheço essa informação
Eliseu Por que que alguns recomendam
ficar 10 minutos no sol para ativar o
ciclo cadian é para você ativar o
relógio interno do do do corpo que
depende de sol Depende de luz tá apenas
um segundo não é o suficiente não seria
o suficiente para ativar o relógio
interno assim como existe aquele livro
americano que ensina a curar osheim Será
que existe também algum livro americano
para TDH não conheço Eliseu tá bom
bem pessoal já estamos com 1 hora de
Live aí agradeço a presença de vocês
eh Tô tendo muitas perguntas aqui mas eu
gostaria que houvesse uma interação
maior né uma
interação pra gente trocar umas ideias
aqui tá vamos ver se a gente consegue
fazer mais isso em lives anteriores um
abraço para vocês até a próxima semana
de nada elu